Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Ben from
San Angelo. Ben, welcome to the program.
Speaker 4: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can.
Speaker 4: All right. So my question today
was actually about polls. A New York Times
and Siena College poll recently found that
there was a 32 point shift in independent women
based on whether they wanted to have Republicans
in office or Democrats in office. My question was,
what do you think is the biggest
reason why there was that shift?
Speaker 1: Now, you didn't say what the
shift was, was assuming this is the same
poll I saw. This is a shift where young women
are have moved more in the direction of the
Democratic Party. Is that right?
Speaker 4: Oh, well, actually,
the poll shows that there was a 32 point swing
among independent women or to vote for the GOP.
Speaker 1: Oh. Okay. Let me pull that
up, then. Independents, especially women,
are swinging. Oh, to the GOP.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah, it's bad. It's.
Speaker 1: I have not seen that poll. And so
it would be mere speculation. I have no idea
why that's going on. It could have something
to do with the specific. I'm just not sure
I have it. I haven't seen that. I've just found
it. Now that you mentioned it, I had not seen
that poll. Does does the do any of the articles
speculate about why that shift has taken place?
Speaker 4: Yes. What I think the biggest
thought is, is that it has the economy.
Abortion. Abortion rights have kind of taken a
backseat. And independent women who were once
furious or upset about the Dobbs decision
are now falling back on the economy. And
I guess they're acclimating to the new world.
Speaker 1: I guess that's a plausible explanation.
And in fact, in a recent segment earlier this
week, I talked about that. Have we just was
the timing of the Roe v Wade decision early
enough that it had an impact and that impact
is now diminishing? I just don't think that
explains a 32 point swing that is massive.
Speaker 4: I guess I wanted the second
question. Then I'll go. And then I had was,
do you think that the Republican tactics of
flipping the debate on abortion saying that
it's the Democrats who are radical for wanting
to keep Roe versus Wade, do you think that that
has been very effective in saying that? No, not.
Speaker 1: At all, because support for Roe v Wade
has only increased since the 1973 decision.
So I can't imagine that that has that. No,
no, no, I don't think so.
Speaker 4: Okay. Thank you
so much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: David My pleasure.
Great to hear from you. Always great to hear from
our friends in San Angelo. As is always the case